I
Fiona Laden being the returning officer
at the web election of stoke-on-trent
north do hereby give notice that the
number of votes recorded for each
candidate at the said election is as
follows
Adams Benedict burn the conservative and
unionist party eighteen thousand nine
hundred and thirty through South Roussel
Douglas Peter
the Green Party 685 Smith Roos
Lauren Labor Party candidate twenty one
thousand two
[Applause]
can I just repeat that figure so it's
clearly hard 20 1272 we learn Richard
more Liberal Democrats 916 the number of
ballot papers rejected was as follows
wanted an official mark 0 voting for
more candidates and the vote was
entitled to 25 writing or mark my which
voted would be identified one being
unlocked or wholly void for in 1797 and
a total rejected with 123 the electorate
is seventy one thousand five hundred and
fifty eight ballot papers issued was
forty 1908 and the turnout is fifty
eight point five seven percent and I do
hereby declare that the said Rose Smith
is duly elected
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen I'll just say a few
words first of all I'd like to thank my
opponents for running such a clean fight
over the last 51 days I think at this
point we're all exhausted but I thank
you very much for the campaign I'd also
like to thank the returning officer and
all the staff here this evening compared
to where we were two years ago this is
an incredibly efficient town and for
that I'm very very grateful also given
the events of the last ten weeks I think
it would be remiss of any of us not to
thank the police for keeping us safe
here but much more importantly for
keeping us safe throughout the country
in recent days I'd very much like to
thank my agent
Kathy volunteers and activists who have
dedicated 51 days to this campaign but
also blood sweat and tears making us be
able to get here this evening it is an
incredible honor to be re-elected as the
Member of Parliament for stoke-on-trent
north and kids growth the fact that I
now get to continue to fight for our
corner to hold the government to account
for you is an extraordinary thing and I
am so grateful and privileged to do it
going forward but tonight's been an
extraordinary night for British politics
the world has changed around us the
Labour Party has won seats from
Canterbury to Scotland this is a very
good night for my party and this was a
clear rejection of seven years of Tory
cuts and austerity we have a weak and
wobbly Prime Minister who needs to
resign because she has done this country
edgy service when we start negotiating
grexit in 11 days this was an
unnecessary election and there are no
consequences for my electorate and for
the country but whatever happens in the
coming days I'll be there to fight for
the people of stoke-on-trent north and
kids grow thanks
[Applause]